have you been dieting and exercising and
not getting the results you desire
the issue could be a fatty liver dr nash
joins us to explain more
hey dr nash how are you i'm great jc how
are you doing today
good good today we're going to talk
about fatty liver because there's many
of us out there that are
dieting and exercising and we're not
losing the weight that we want and you
say could be
because of fatty liver and that there
are three reasons why
fatty liver is preventing weight loss
what are they
yeah and what's worse is fatty liver now
affects 45
of the population including children and
there's no
medical treatment or drug and there's no
symptoms so the doctors aren't really
telling us
that it's going on and it does it makes
fat loss virtually impossible
when i'm going on a diet so even if i'm
eating less and moving more that fatty
liver is stopping me from burning that
body fat
what are some of the symptoms how can
someone tell that they have a fatty
liver
there's actually two physical criteria
um
that you can do to find out if you have
fatty liver when people sign up for my
evaluation i give them that information
so that they can find out if it's going
on
but because only the liver turned your
body fat into energy
it's very very critical that we get that
liver taken care of especially if
permanent weight loss is the goal
so i take it that traditional diet and
exercise is not the answer so then what
is the solution
for fatty liver the fatty liver has
absolutely nothing to do
with how much you exercise and in fact
certain foods that we're being told to
eat that are supposed to be healthy and
make us lose weight
will actually only make the liver worse
it'll literally stop proper liver
function
including fat metabolism dr nash part of
your transformation program is the five
metabolic factors
explain those to everyone yeah so
basically this is what i discovered in
order for me to fix
a 25 year long fight with obesity there
are five things that can be going on
inside our bodies that
literally block the abilities the body's
ability to burn body fat
the first one is going to be toxicity
this is the liver this is the situation
going on with the fatty liver
the next one is going to be where i'm
over fed but undernourished i'm getting
enough calories
but i'm got not getting enough nutrition
to actually fix the damage
the second one is that if i've been
sitting at the high weight for so long i
have literally retrained a lower part of
my brain to hold that weight and keep me
there
the final one is acidity or inflammation
and inflammation
drives weight gain especially to the
belly
and then the last one is lower imbalance
hormones up to seven
different hormones that are like a light
switch and if they're in the wrong
position
you could be in a calorie deficit but
not burning body fat
it's amazing how you've broken all of
this down dr national what's even more
amazing are the specials that you bring
to our show
what do you have for us this week yes so
of course whenever anybody wants to do
the evaluation
with me that is the first step to find
out if you're having these issues that i
work with
normally the evaluation is 97 but if you
say that you saw me on las vegas now
with jc
i'm going to have 10 spots available
where not only is there a reduced price
on the evaluation at 9.97 there's a
reduced price on the program as well
because we want to get you the help that
you need to get the weight off for good
take advantage of dr nash's special
offer by giving her a call
with on the number on your screen or
visit drnash.com
forward slash eval las vegas now we'll
be right back